>> Greg: YESTERDAY AND
ABORTION RALLY, CHUCK SCHUMER
THE MASTER OF HEARTFELT SENATE
HYPOCRISY SAID THIS.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU GORSUCH
COME I WANT TO TELL YOU,
KAVANAUGH, YOU HAVE RELEASED THE
WHIRLWINDS AND YOU WILL PAY THE
PRICE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU WILL NOT KNOW WHAT HIT YOU
TO GO FORWARD WITH THESE AWFUL
DECISIONS.
>> Greg: OUTRAGEOUS STUFF.
EVEN CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
SAID IT WAS DANGEROUS.
CHUCK SCHUMER’S OFFICE OFFERED A
COWARDLY LIST LIGHT AND MEANING
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD PAY AND NOT
THE JUDGES.
AND WE KNOW THAT HIS FOAL’S
BECAUSE THAT MOVEMENT ALREADY
EXIST.
I WANT TO TELL YOU SENATOR,
NEVER BEFORE IN THE HISTORY HAS
A NONPOOR EVER FACED HATE
BECAUSE THEY ARE A BAG OF CELLS.
AND LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE CONCEIVED
AFTER THESE LUCKY WOMEN WERE
BORN.
>> ABORTIONS ARE ONE OF
PROCEDURES YOU CAN DO ON AN
OUTPATIENT BASIS.
SAFER THAN DOING AN EXTRACTION.
>> TODAY, WE ARE TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM INCLUDING
ABORTION FOR EXACTLY WHAT IT IS,
NO LESS THAN LIBERTY ITSELF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE WILL NEVER STOP TALKING
ABOUT ABORTION.
>> Greg: THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO WHAT IS CHUCK SCHUMER REALLY?
HE’S NOT A FIREBRAND OR BOMB
THROWER, HE IS JUST A FOLLOWER,
FOLLOWING THEM.
THE ABORTION MOVEMENT HAS MOVED
FROM THE VALLEY OF ABORTIONS
BEING LEGAL AND RARE TO COME
ONE, COME ALL.
IT IS IRRATIONAL AND WANT WANT A
NICE SCIENCE AFTER A WAY TO DENY
LIMITS TO DEMANDS.
IN THIS MOVE WHERE ABORTION IS
NO LONGER A TRAGIC DECISION BUT
A CHOICE TO BE CHAMPION, LAUGHED
ABOUT, EVEN BRAGGED ABOUT, IT IS
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT A WEAK AND
ANXIOUS MAN LIKE CHUCK WOULD
FIND HIMSELF SWEPT UP IN THE
HAWKISH FEVER FOR CASUAL
TERMINATION OF THE SMALL AND
INCONVENIENT.
FUNNY HOW SOME IN THE MEDIA
WORRY THE JUDGES WERE BEING
THREATENED.
NO, CHUCK IS JUST ANOTHER EMPTY,
GRAND STANDING JOKE.
THE JUDGES CAN TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
PITY THOSE WHO NEVER HAVE THAT
CHANCE.
SO JUDGE, I’M GOING TO HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE, WE WOULD LOVE YOU
TOO, AFTER WE PLAY AT.
LET’S DO IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
>> I’M FROM BROOKLYN AND WE
SPEAK AND STRONG LANGUAGE.
I SHOULD NOT HAVE USED THE WORDS
I DID, BUT IN NO WAY WAS I
MAKING A THREAT.
I NEVER, EVER WOULD DO SUCH A
THING.
>> Greg: SO NOW HE’S FROM
BROOKLYN AND IS USING THAT
EXCUSE, JUDGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I NEVER,
EVER WOULD DO SUCH A THING?
HE SAID THAT GORSUCH, KAVANAUGH,
YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE AND YOU
WON’T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU.
HE WAS NOT TALKING ABOUT
ANYTHING BUT THOSE JUSTICES.
HE WAS INTIMIDATING THEM.
HE WAS THREATENING THEM.
HE WAS CALLING A MOB TO --
CALLING ON A MOB, INCITING, AS
FAR AS I AM CONCERNED, VIOLENCE.
OKAY, THAT IS A CALL TO ACTION.
IN REAL TIME WHILE THE
SUPREME COURT JUST OUTSIDE OF
HIS HEARING THE VERY CASE OF
CONCERN.
IT IS THE FIRST ABORTION CASE
SINCE THESE TWO NEW JUDGES HAS
TAKEN THEIR SEAT ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
SO WHEN THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT COMES OUT AND SAYS
THAT IT IS A DANGEROUS THREAT,
YOU CAN REST ASSURED THAT IT IS
A THREAT.
AND WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
THESE JUDGES HAVE A LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT.
SO IT’S NOT LIKE THEY CAN GET
THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
IT’S NOT LIKE THEY CAN, YOU
KNOW, CALL THEM OR HAVE SOMEONE
RUN AGAINST THEM.
IT IS BASICALLY POLITICIZING THE
SUPREME COURT AND IT IS
BASICALLY THREATENING THEM.
AND THERE ARE THOSE CALLING UPON
CHUCK SCHUMER TO BE NUMBER ONE,
PROSECUTED, NUMBER TWO CALLING
UPON HIM TO RESIGN, NUMBER 3K TO
STEP DOWN FROM HIS POSITION
AS MINORITY LEADER AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT SOMEONE IMPEACH
HIM WHICH I THINK WOULD BE
POETIC JUSTICE.
BUT THIS IS THE SAME GUY WHO
SAID YOU MESS WITH THE INTEL
COMMUNITY AND THEY WILL MESS
WITH YOU SIX WAYS TO SUNDAY.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO AMERICANS
FOR TWO YEARS.
HE’S AT IT AGAIN.
>> Greg: JUAN, MY FEELING IS
HE WAS PLAYING TO THE CROWD, BUT
PRO-CHOICE PEOPLE AND I KNOW A
LOT OF THEM.
I THINK YOU ARE PRO-CHOICE COME
I THINK, HAVE TO CONTEMPLATE THE
INTENSITY OF THAT FETAL HATE
THAT YOU WERE SEEING.
LIKE BUBBLING OUT OF THAT GROUP.
HE GOT SUCKERED INTO THAT.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK THAT IS
TRUE.
FIRST OF ALL --
>> Greg: THEY ARE SCARING THE
DEATH OF UNBORN CHILDREN.
>> Juan: AS YOU SAID I’M
PRO-CHOICE.
I HAVE 11 CHILDREN IN MY FAMILY.
ABORTION IS A RECORD LOW RATE IN
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
BUT I DO THINK, WHAT STRIKES ME
AND COMES TO YOUR POINT, JUDGE,
THAT WE SEE THE CHIEF JUSTICE
RESPOND.
I WAS TAKEN BY THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, CHUCK SCHUMER AND
MITCH McCONNELL AND OTHERS
COME AT THE CHIEF JUSTICE SAID
THAT WAS A DANGEROUS COMMENT,
RIGHT?
THEN I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, BUT
THE CHIEF JUSTICE DIDN’T SAY
ANYTHING WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS
GOING AFTER SONIA SOTOMAYOR.
>> Jesse: E DIDN’T SAY
ANYTHING WHEN HE SAID THAT
MEXICAN CAN’T BE A JUDGE.
>> Juan: WAIT, YOU DON’T WANT
TO HEAR THIS.
IT STRIKES ME THAT WHAT WE SEE
AS THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID AND
BRAGGED ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
CONSERVATIVES HE HAS PUT ON THE
COURT.
HE BRAGS ABOUT HAVING --
>> Greg: SO --
>> Jesse: STOMACH >> Juan:
HE SHOWS UP AT A ABORTION RALLY.
>> Greg:>> Jesse: HE DIDN’T GO T
JUDGES OFFICE AND PART OF A TASK
IN FRONT OF A HUGE, THREATENING
CROWD.
>> HE WAS ON THE SUPREME COURT
JUAN IN FRONT OF AN ANGRY,
SCREAMING CROWD.
>> Greg: JUAN, LET’S BE
HONEST.
THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO FOR A
PRO-LIFER IS SET UP
NICHOLAS SANDMANN, THAT’S ALL
YOU CAN DO.
DANA COME I WANT TO ASK YOU,
WHAT BOTHERS ME IS I’M PRO-LIFE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT ABORTION IS
HERE APPEAR THERE IS NOTHING YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO DO ABOUT IT, BUT
WE SEE THAT AND WE REALIZE IT’S
MOVED AWAY FROM REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS TO FETAL FASCISM.
IT’S LIKE, IF YOU ARE NOT PART
OF THEIR BATTLE WHERE THAT SIDE
OF THE WAR, YOU ARE AS GOOD AS
DEAD.
>> Dana: IT IS REALLY
INTERESTING TOO, CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS ALWAYS SAID AFTER THE
CONFIRMATION HEARING IN 2005, HE
BELIEVES IN THE PRESIDENT AND
THESE ABORTION CASES COMING
THEIR WAY, HE IS RELUCTANT TO BE
GUIDING THIS ONE TO OVERTURN
ROE V. WADE.
THEY MIGHT DO IT EVENTUALLY, I
DON’T KNOW, THIS CASE OUT OF
LOUISIANA HAS ONE OF THEM.
BUT THE OTHER THING IS, JUST THE
OTHER NIGHT WE HAD SUPER TUESDAY
AND WE HAVE FOX NEWS VOTER
ANALYSIS FROM EACH STATE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ISSUES WHAT
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES TO
YOU, THIS IS DEMOCRATS,
HEALTH CARE, AND IT WAS JOBS,
THEN EMPLOYMENT.
AND THEN 1%.
AND ALMOST EVERY SINGLE THING
COME ABORTION.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND FROM A
POLITICAL STANDPOINT DOESN’T
HAVE TO FACE THE SAME CROWD.
HE DOESN’T HAVE TO GO TO BE A
PART OF IT BUT HE GOT CHOSE TO
AND GOT CAUGHT UP IN IT AND IT’S
LIKE STEPPING ON A BREAK ON THE
SENATE FLOOR.
>> Juan: I THINK ABORTION
THOUGH, IS OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE.
BUT THE SUPREME COURT, WHICH IS
A REAL TOKEN FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT I’VE PUT
TWO CONSERVATIVE JUDGES ON THE
COURT AND IT WILL BE A BIG ISSUE
IN NOVEMBER.
NOW FOR DEMOCRATS AND I THINK
THIS SIGNALS HOW IMPORTANT IT